ja einen schönen guten morgen oder
schönen guten tag aber von meiner seite
vielen dank für die einladung an die
möglichkeit heute das thema blackout
auch in dieser runde
darzustellen viele von den teilnehmern
kennen mich ich bin
mittlerweile international blackwater um
krisenvorsorge experte wie bin ich dass
geworden war bis 2002 fünf selber
sicherheitsbereich tätig noch vor über
zehn jahren berufsbegleitend ein studium
begonnen wollte mich damals mit cyber
sicherheit und chris management auf
staatlicher ebene beschäftigen internet
smart metering eher zufällig auf das
thema stromversorgung gestoßen und das
hat man dann immer los gelassen weil die
frage ob da gibt es gewisse tendenzen
entwicklungen die vielleicht nicht so
positiv sind auf der anderen seite
fühlte sich damals zum teil auch heute
noch niemand richtig zuständig
verantwortlich wird das thema was ist
wenn das größer ausfällt welche
vorsorgemaßnahmen gibt
und da habe ich dann 2012 beschlossen
auszusteigen und das auf eigene faust
weiter zu machen
entwicklungen haben wir leider recht
gegeben wo ich bisher unrecht hatte zum
glück war dass das ereignis doch noch
nicht eingetreten ist aber
damals war das eher theoretischer ansatz
heute sind wieder dinge in der praxis
bestätigt
ja das zu meinem hintergrund
und mein übergeordnetes thema ist immer
vernetzung komplexität was durch die
vernetzung mit uns als gesellschaft und
da geht es vor allem darum zusammenhänge
zu erkennen als systemisches komplexität
wissenschaftliches denken
dass mich auch da begeistert dass ich
auch durch dieses studium auch eher
zufällig nicht durch das studium selbst
sondern entdeckt habe dass das meine
passion ist und da ist auch ein
wichtiger grundsatz das verständnis für
diese teils ergibt sich stets aus der
kenntnis des ganzen nicht umgekehrt für
uns soldaten offiziere ist es nur
verständlich kampf der verbundenen
waffen passt grundsätzlich in dieses
thema ein
wobei es fielen noch nicht so bewusst
ist weil man das vor allem wenn man das
weiterdenkt eben nicht nur waffen geht
sondern um das generelle thema
vernetztes denken
ja ich starte das ganze mit einem
kleinem gedankenexperiment stellen sie
sich vor das stromfeld jetzt aus
japan passieren wird man merken der
schirm ist komplett schwarz computer ist
weg die ich das weg
kann der lokalauswahl sein könnte jetzt
im raum sein sie wird noch mal versuchen
festzustellen was ist los
und dann merken ob lässt die sicherungen
sind alle in ordnung
und es scheint nicht im haus in der
wohnung zu liegen sondern kosten
irgendwo aber welche weiteren schritte
werden dann vorgesehen um festzustellen
ist dass wir jetzt einfach lokal
ausfälle und größerer ausfall was würde
ihre familien zu machen die kinder vor
allem oder enkeln wo sind die gerade
sind schon in der schule oder weg in der
schule
was passiert mit den öffentlichen
verkehr wo es ihr partner partnerin
wenn jetzt nicht im home office ist
und was wir jetzt in ihrer einheit in
organisation anlaufen gibt es eine
notstromversorgung
prora welche schritte werden jetzt zu
prüfen um festzustellen was los ist und
dann kommt doch eine meldung von
irgendwo anders her über ein smartphone
dass es sich auch dort um den strom
ausfallen hat das heißt erster hinweist
dass es doch größer ist und
damit auch die letzte meldung diese
wahrscheinlich für die nächste woche
über dieses medium erhalten
wir warten weiter normal konto strom aus
weniger minuten oder manchmal auch
wenigen stunden wieder zurück eine
größere störung im lokalen bereich ist
aber diesmal nicht dann mag man
informationen jahren radio einschalten
da wird hoffentlich auch bald was kommen
oder bald noch ein zwei stunden
und dann die information er ist größer
betrifft weiter teile europas und wird
wahrscheinlich länger dauern und welche
schritte würden jetzt konkret im
bundesheer in anderen organisationen
laufen oder würden welche anlaufen was
ist vorbereitet und wie geht der tag
weiter am abend noch immer keinen strom
das heißt halt er sehr früh finster was
passiert jetzt und in der nacht wurden
in der früh meldung meter vom radio es
sollte jetzt den teil meter funktioniert
es kommt dann auch in der am vormittag
der strom wieder und was wäre dann würde
das einfach normal weitergehen wie
bisher
oder hätte sich etwas geändert
beziehungsweise wie geht's weiter sie
haben zur natürlichen berlin intensiv
damit beschäftigt und
daher klar dass es nicht einfach
weitergeht aber ich glaube dass man mit
dem durchaus auch zum nachdenken anregen
kann und nicht alle den wissenstand
haben
und so oder so ähnlich könnte sich dann
abspielt wird zum blackout kommt was mir
immer ganz wichtig ist dass auch vorweg
zu definieren weil vielen nicht bewusst
das um was es wirklich geht und auch
nach wie vor katastrophenschutz
verantwortlicher funktion
unterschiedlichen szenarien und sprechen
da geht es auch darum wenn in
ostösterreich oder teilen österreichs
der strom ausfällt damit das auch als
black out bezeichnet und ich halte das
für irritierend auch in der
außenkommunikation
weil man damit völlig unterschiedliche
dinge miteinander verbindet und wenn ich
vom blackout sprecher dann geht es um
einen plötzlichen überregionalen das
heißt weite teile europas betreffenden
und länger andauerten kommen noch dazu
strom das ist das auslöser eines aber
vor allem infrastruktur unter
versorgungs haus frei und das was viele
noch nicht bewusst ist ist das der
versorgung sonst vorauswahl uns dass
gesellschaft nach wenigen tagen an den
punkt bringt wo man einfach nicht mehr
als er rasch zurück kommen
man könnte das auch noch zusätzlich gab
grenzen eine hilfe von außerhalb ist
nicht möglich das heißt was bei lokalen
regionalen ausfällen mögliches wie die
ab 2014 in slowenien muss diesen
großflächigen ausfall gab dass
hilfskräfte aus zehn ländern dort zum
einsatz kommen um schlimmeres zu
verhindern er ist funktioniert da nicht
oder aktuell im aartal in deutschland wo
im juli die gesamte infrastruktur über
30 kilometer zerstört worden ist
und noch immer keine infrastruktur mehr
verfügbar ist da können hilfskräfte von
außerhalb doch schlimmeres verhindern
aber beim blick hat funktioniert das
eben nicht
und auch diese übung jetzt am 12
november da wurde immer vom blackout
übrigen gesprochen in wirklichkeit wurde
eine strom angela geübt vom inhalt her
und dann in der außenkommunikation
behauptet österreich ist gut auf ein
black out vorbereitet also sehr viele
falsche informationen weil es war kein
blackout übung weil das kommt was anders
ist die stromer gelage bedeutet ich sehe
in ein paar tagen wird das zu wenig
strom geben und man muss setzt teile
abschalten zum minister gewisse zeit für
mehrere stunden um ein blackout zu
verhindern das heißt ich kann noch
kommen kommunizieren ich kann doch was
organisieren ich kann einen raum des
ausfalls eingrenzen und das ist ein ganz
anderes szenario
auch wenn die schweiz das 2014
gesamtstaatlich auch übt hat und dann
festgestellt hat wenn das über längere
zeit dass mehrere wochen oder noch
länger gehen sollte es durchaus auch
massive probleme hervorrufen würde und
fast noch schlimmer wir haben ja ein
blackout
weil im windkanal stromabschaltungen und
rollieren stattfinden müssen wie der zu
den in südafrika wieder oder in china
dann bedeutet das dass viele andere
versorgungsleistung auch nicht
funktionieren und
daher bitte auch in der
außenkommunikation im bundesheer darauf
achten dass man genau dieses thema auch
mein und das auch klarer ansprechen
damit auch nicht falsche bilder
entstehen
die frage ist natürlich wie
wahrscheinlich ist ein solches ereignis
die positive nachricht es gibt keine
evidenz das heißt ein solches sagen es
gab es in europa noch nicht
es gibt weltweit immer wieder das letzte
black ort war am neunten jener 2021 in
pakistan wobei das war jetzt glaube ich
dass tritte in den letzten jahren also
dort ist man durchaus gewohnt dass das
häufig auftritt auch in den usa in
louisiana wurden nach dem hurrikan drei
wochen für gebiet von 600.000 menschen
der strom aus
wobei dort man das auch häufiger lebt in
dieser dauer haben wahrscheinlich auch
nicht aber man hat trotzdem
vorbereitungen um mit uns umzugehen und
das ist gleichzeitig die große gefahr
mitteleuropa speziell aber auch
insgesamt europa weil wir so eine hohe
versorgungssicherheit in allen
lebensbereichen haben sind ja nicht mehr
gewohnt damit umzugehen und es gibt auch
kaum rück verlieren was das ganze
natürlich verschärft und daher gibt es
in meiner fachwelt auch die sogenannte
total illusion die besagt der truthahn
gewinnt mit jeder fütterung das
vertrauen in seinem besitz aber der kann
sie nur gut meinen weil ihm täglich
versorgt und füttern das problem ist im
feld gewesen nicht informationen dass
das eben nur einen zweck dient das er
dann verspeist wird und wir ticken so
ähnlich wie schon in den rückspiegel da
gibt es dann auch die statistiken die
das angeblich unterstreiche mir super
das ist und dass das in zukunft auch so
sein wird
und das könnte so bösen überraschung
werden
und entscheidend ist werden wir darauf
vorbereitet und das kann ich noch jetzt
fast zehn jahren auseinandersetzt oder
zehn jahren auseinandersetzung mit dem
thema mitgeben kern nein beantworten und
alle die etwas gegenteiliges behaupten
haben das thema noch nicht verstanden
oder lügen sich selbst an weil auf
dieses thema kann man eigentlich nie gut
genug vorbereitet sein man kann
natürlich versuchen bestmöglich
etwas zu tun aber in der gesamtheit ist
einfach mein und es hilft auch nichts
wenn einzelne bereiche einzelne
organisationen vielleicht auch gut für
den stromausfall aufgestellt sind das
stimmt schon aber für die black ort
bewältigung als ganzes ist das völlig
irrelevant
ja es gibt auch im bundesheer diese
sicherheitspolitische
einschätzung erstmals 2020 klar
kommuniziert man rechnet binnen der
nächsten fünf jahre damit
wobei immer wichtig diese fünf jahre
sind nicht ein datum das heißt bis 2025
sollen kurzfristig das bedeutet das
calwer morgen passieren das kann simon
und passieren oder auch erst in sieben
jahren aber es gibt sehr viel ernster
als punkte und und anzeichen dass wir
das erleben werden und da werde ich auch
noch eingehen weil deswegen mich bewusst
ist fast alles zusammenhängt um rund es
wirklich so eine große gefahr ist und
meine persönliche einschätzung jetzt
nach zehn jahren beobachten was sich im
europäischen verbund system tut und was
in den nächsten monaten geplant ist
möchte ich dass es bereits im coebad
wing dass er ja kritischer werden kann
ich habe kürzlich am vortrag in leipzig
auch gehalten vor kritischen
infrastruktur betreibern und dann meldet
sich jemand aus der energiewirtschaft
netzbetriebs seite zu wort sagt ja kann
alles unterstreichen was ich gesagt habe
aber eine folie die die es falsch das
ist nämlich diese vollem umfang dieses
rufzeichen und die nächsten monate weil
sie aber alles im griff ich hoffe und
ich hoffe immer dass ich falsch liege
und ihre band hoffnung das einzige ist
was wir dagegen halten können
ist es einfach unzureichend
warum die nächsten monate das komme ich
gleich dazu auch noch
ja und es gab ja auch jetzt ende
september diese pressekonferenz mit dem
innenminister und aus dem baur grip
weich im live auftritt sehr klartext
auch gesprochen wurde er wurde aus dem
bauch da gehabt christina klar gesagt
hat wir fahren nicht permanent am limit
wo auch der innenminister sehr klar zur
eigenvorsorge aufgefordert hat das
problem war nur dass das in den medien
dann nicht mehr aus einem niederschlag
fahren da wurde nur die presseaussendung
übernommen kopp mp ist mehr oder weniger
mit informationen und die polizei
vorbereitet und dann erst eine nachfrage
ergab sowie im video die aussage ist ja
man hat jetzt begonnen und 2024 ist es
soweit dass die ersten polizei zu
stellen oder die ersten 100 sollen dann
auch zu mit strom technischer taxi
und der gips tausenden eindruck der
heute sehr viel des freitodes gerne
kümmern zentrum auch beim bundesheer auf
weil sie doch auch einige berichte gibt
wo dann schon im unter texterin entsteht
ja man es dabei aber in der gesellschaft
in den unternehmen ist oft die
wahrnehmung die organisation und sind
bereits vorbereitet nicht werden erst
vorbereitet und das ist auch kritisch
weil er falsche erwartungen einfach
bestehen
ja und bevor ich zum thema black
konkrete gehe die fragestellung gibt es
ein problem weil diese zusammenhänge
selten bewusst sind und ich war erst
letztes wochenende in der schweiz noch
in zürich um auf eine veranstaltung die
durfte noch stattfinden
und danach ist ein vertreter des
regulators des schweizer regulators zu
mir kunden hat sie dann bedankt works at
vom fach und der beschäftigt sie auch
damit aber er hat auch noch einiges
dazugelernt
ja das hat mich natürlich besonders
gefreut weil hat viele dinge nicht jetzt
im alltag so aufpoppen wie ich das dann
noch konzentriert darstelle und der ist
es auch wichtig in der kommunikation als
hintergrund wenn sie gefragt werden dass
sie das eine oder andere dann vielleicht
auch da hat so erklären können
zunächst einmal ist wichtig dass wir ein
europäisches verbundsystem haben das
heißt wenn die medien schaut und die
berichte da geht es immer um
österreicher österreichische
energieversorgung ist gut aufgestellt da
stimmt wir sind wirklich gut aufgestellt
einerseits von der biografie her mit
unserer wasserkraft um
speicherkraftwerken und auch weil die
energiewirtschaft sich gut vorbereitet
und wirklich viel macht nur wir sitzen
mit 35 anderen ländern im von portugal
bis in die osttürkei und von sizilien
bis nach dänemark in den gemeinsamen
boot und wenn es in diesem system aber
größere störung geben sollte das zum
blackout führt dann sitzen gemeinsam im
boot und mitten drinnen und der erste
chance recht groß dass wir mit absaufen
und da hilft es nichts wenn wir unsere
hausaufgaben gemacht haben sondern es
müssten alle 36 die hausaufgaben machen
und das ist nicht überall gleich gut und
vor allem unseren nördlichen nachbarn
deutschland macht mir besonders sorgen
weil er einfach viele maßnahmen
getroffen werden die jetzt außensicht
systemischer sicht nicht gut gehen werde
und wir haben ja ein system des too big
to fail ist das heißt zu groß um
versagen zu dürfen kämen aus dem
finanzwesen wo man gesagt man kann
gewisse große banken nicht kreischen
lassen weil sie dann einfach kippen
wegzoll auslösen würden und beim
stromversorgungssystem weil es so groß
ist haben wir dieses problem auch diese
größe auch durchaus vorteile weil es
damit auch zum stabilsten weltweit einig
geworden ist durch diese vernetzung und
diesen austausch aber wenn das einmal
ins trudeln gerät dann ist der schaden
unverhältnismäßig größer also man kann
daher durchaus auch von gewissen
exponentiellen entwicklungen sprechen
und so über das jetzt vom coroner kennen
exponentiell dhz ist es überschaubar und
irgendwo erreicht man mit der gewissen
größe des ausfalls einfach
exponentiellen anstieg in den
auswirkungen in dem vollen und auch in
der wiederherstellungszeit und das ist
glaube ich vielen nicht bewusst
und ja und es gibt eben keine 100
prozentige sicherheit wie ja auch den
europäischen netzbetreiber 2015 im
bericht zum blackout in der türkei
festgehalten haben und das ist halt
außerhalb der branche oder der fach
organe nicht mehr braucht selbst über
bekannt aber schon bald außerhalb und da
ist es eine fahrlässigkeit dabei dass
wir als gesellschaft einfach annehmen
das funktioniert der ema und wir
brauchen uns um nichts kümmern
und wichtiges technisches detail ist
dass man im wechsel stromsystem
permanente balance zwischen erzeugung
und verbrauch sicherstellen muss dass es
muss immer genau so viel erzeugt werden
wie gerade verbraucht wird auf dem der
verbrauch natürlich variables ist es
nicht ganz trivial
das funktioniert aber in diesem großes
den deswegen besonders gut weil es hier
spezielle elemente gibt nämlich die
rotierenden massen die momentan das
erfurter generatoren der großkraftwerke
die sind so eine art stoßdämpfer die ja
einfach diese schwankungen im kleinen
laufend ausgleichen und da wird einfach
mechanische energie
gespeichert und in elektrische
umgewandelt oder umgekehrt durch diese
rotierten maßen und das problem ist dass
wir zunehmend mehr konventionelle
kraftwerke vor allem fossile kraftwerke
stilling aus klimaschutzgründen
natürlich notwendig das problem ist aber
dass befund wird diese funktionalität
nicht aufweisen
und
auch nicht kurzfristig in großen mengen
ersetzt werden kann es gibt zwei ansätze
mit leistungselektronik um großspeicher
aber dass ein neues pilotprojekte
derzeit
die alternative wir haben uns den
generator weiterlaufen ob er das nicht
die gesamte menge dann ist die da
drinnen steckt weil er dann auch die
dampf einheit fehlt und es ist auch
einige sprecher
und das muss man auch erst und bauen das
kann man jetzt einfach nur am netz
lassen sondern muss man auch umbauen und
jetzt schalten wir in deutschland große
mengen konventionelle kraftwerke ab
nämlich heuer bis jahresende treibt
große atomkraftwerke die halb österreich
voll versorgen könnten und die doppelte
menge kohlekraftwerke wohl schon teile
mit erstem jänner vom netz gegangen sind
das erste drittel ist von dieser
gesamtmenge am ersten jänner vom netz
gegangen und musste zum teil wieder
macht jener eingeschaltet werden weiß
ich nicht ausgegangen ist und jetzt hat
man die dreifache menge ob und jetzt
schauen wir auf was passiert
offensichtlich
und daher als wichtiger faktor nicht nur
die leistung die damit weg geht da gibt
es noch genügend gas kraftwerke sondern
von diesem system stabilisierten
elemente die verloren gehen und beim gas
haben wir noch zusätzlich das problem
dass die gaslagerstätten in deutschland
österreich aber insgesamt in der eu
deutlich unter dem üblichen gefüllt sind
wir aber heuer
durch das noch steigern und größeren
gasverbrauch haben werden und sollte
danach erhält der wähler das wort dazu
kommen das heißt hörer gas verbraucht
dann könnte das ganze ziemlich eng
werden das heißt dass wir nicht über die
runden kommen ob es zum blackout kommt
das weiß ich natürlich auch nicht aber
das risiko war noch nie so hoch wie in
den kommenden wochen im winter jetzt
und das ganze geht aber weiter dass
nächstes jahr ja nochmal die gleiche
menge an atom- und kohlekraftwerken in
deutschland abgeschaltet werden
das heißt es wird sich im laufe des
nächsten jahres noch weiter verschärfen
speziell gegen ende des jahres bei der
atomkraftwerke york weg gehen
und
die frage ist wie das dann funktioniert
das wird meistens beantwortet wie auch
wir importieren einfach aus den
nachbarländern und dann sage ich immer
das ist sehr spannend weil ich beobachte
seit jahren den weg geben und wenn es
eng geworden ist dann haben immer die
nachbarländer aus deutschland importiert
und erzeugt deutschen wie importieren
auch
dann ist die frage ob die anderen
exportieren können und sonst wird es
eben zu diesen flächen abschaltungen
kommen müssen darum ist auch das thema
stromberg lage im jahr locker thema also
das ist hoffentlich zuerst vom blackout
weil das dann hoffentlich doch ein
bisschen mehr erwarten würde
ja und dann gab es noch grundsätzlich
die planung mit dem atomausstieg der vor
zehn jahren fixiert wurde dass bis 2022
mehrere groß leitungen von norden
deutschlands in den süden gehen müssen
damit
der wienstrom so vernarrt ist in den
süden transportiert werden kann nur
gebraucht wird und das problem ist dass
diese leitungen nicht bis 2022 fertig
sind sondern die erste es frühestens
2028 fertig das heißt wir haben
zumindest sechs jahre massive probleme
jetzt den strom dorthin zu bekommen wo
er gebraucht wird und es ist ja nicht
nur in deutschland auch in österreich
kann man das problem mit der
salzburgleitung die jetzt gebaut wird
bis 2025 und auch in anderen ländern
gibt es entsprechende probleme
und dann gibt es im weitere stressoren
die das ganze zusätzlich ja fragilen
machen das eine ist der strommarkt wir
haben eben durch den strommarkt
liberalisierung vor 20 jahren eine
auftrennung zwischen kraftwerksbetrieb
der sich selbst optimieren muss
natürlich betriebswirtschaftlich
möglichst viel gewinn machen soll dann
gibt es den netzbetrieb der hat einen
transport des stroms sicherstellt und
dann gibt es den handel und vertrieb und
er können wir per mausklick den
stromanbieter wechseln weil das nur
virtuell acis und mittags sieg nichts zu
tun hat
und der stromhandel hat per definition
die aufgabe möglichst viel gewinn oder
günstige preis herauszuschlagen
und die wird immer wieder gezockt und
das war schon mehrfach daneben weil dann
die wetterprognosen nicht gestimmt kommt
weil gewisse marktregeln heute
zugelassen haben und da waren wir schon
mehr vorkommen limit wo ein weiteres
eigen ist das ganze zum crash hätte
bringen können und wir haben jetzt fast
täglich wieder
bis zu zweimal am tag solche situationen
wo durch diesen optimierten fahrplan des
handels und der kraftwerksbetreiber
einfach frequenz einbrüche stattfinden
wo die hälfte bis zwei drittel der
erfolge halten oder sehr welcher
kraftwerks ausfälle durch diese vag
spiele aufgebraucht werden das heißt
wenn es zu diesem zeitpunkt was durchaus
wahrscheinlich ist noch zu sagen
kraftwerks ausfall kommt wird es geben
beim schichtwechsel ist dann könnte das
ziemlich schnell in die hosen gehen man
weiß wie man das technisch abstellen
könnte durch entsprechende vorgaben das
wird aber von der politik und regulation
nicht akzeptiert und der formel 3 fache
risiko das vielen nicht bewusst ist dann
haben wir das thema erneuerbare bild das
häufig in den medien abtransportiert
wird wobei meine aussage ist die
erneuerbaren sind nicht per se schuld
und die regulation und politik die
einfach der falsche anreize gesetzt hat
und anreize setzt weil man nur die
erzeugung im fokus hat und jetzt hängt
sie zwei monate in der mitte jänner und
juni vom heurigen jahr in deutschland
weil es dort diese grafik gibt
und die roten zeigten das ist der
verbrauch und blaues windstromproduktion
und gelb ist photovoltaik
stromproduktion das heißt wir haben das
ja unterschiedliche erzeugungs
charakteren und wie ich schon gesagt
habe aber der verbrauch muss ständig mit
dem mit erzeugung übereinstimme
haben wir da natürlich ein massives
problem dass das nicht ist und es können
noch die konventionellen kraftwerke
ausgleichen so lange noch genug da sind
und zum anderen führt das dazu dass
diese großkraftwerke nie für so ein
wechsel betrieb gebaut worden sind
und wenn man ständig an und opfert dann
führt das nicht nur beziehung zur
systemsicherheit weil dann einfach die
auswahl wahrscheinlichkeit steigt und
das große thema ist eben das thema
speicher fehlende speicher und die hier
sehen sie den august letzten jahres in
deutschland nur
durch erneuerbare 71 gigawatt strom
erzeugt worden sind das war der
bisherige höhepunkt und 30 stunden
später waren es dann nur mehr 95
gigawatt heißt mehr bruchteil und wenn
man nur diese eine stunde herausnimmt
vom tiefpunkt wie für strom wartet da da
gefehlt hat da man das 52 gigawatt
stunden und es entspricht den
speicherinhalt des größten
pumpspeicherkraftwerks des in
deutschland existiert nämlich dieses
goldisthal
und auch wenn das mehrfach existieren
würde man konnte nicht in einer stunde
dieses becken ausleeren es werde auch
nicht funktioniert aber nur um die
dimension mal so klar zu machen
hinzu kommt dass in ganz deutschland nur
40 gigawattstunden
und speicherkapazitäten zur verfügung
stehen was die effizienteste speicher
ist denn wir derzeit kennen im vergleich
dazu in österreich haben wir 3000 300
gigawattstunden
das heißt der vielfraß wobei auch das
nur theoretische zahl es die maximal
sonde 2700 gegenwart stunden wirklich
gefüllt sind und heuer aber mal im mai
schon ziemlich weit unten nämlich auf
450 gigawattstunden
man kann die bag noch nicht ganz
erklären also da ist dann schon ziemlich
schnell schluss und das große thema sein
wie es will deutschland das auf die
reihe kriegen wenn sie aus atom kohle
aussteigen keine speicher haben und
jetzt auch reich diskutieren ob nicht
die gaskraftwerke auch gleich ab drinnen
wenn sie deutschland abschalten das war
wohl den song dann wird das
funktionieren aber
wird es eher in die katastrophe führen
ja dann ein anderer blick zum einen nach
burgenland weil das ja immer wieder der
aussage burgenland dass eine attac das
stimmt übers jahr gerechnet aber nicht
instanz so wie es für die
systemsicherheit notwendig wir uns dass
boni und wäre obwohl es vier bis fünf
fragen des strombedarfs übers jahr
gerechnet produzieren mit der
windkrafträder
würden wir uns das ganze jahr finster
sein weil das technisch alleine nicht
funktionieren würde und wenn man das mit
direktem mobilität auch in zusammenhang
bringt
so wie jetzt die letzten tage der wind
optimal wird optimal war aber dann
kommen also durchaus 80 gigawattstunden
überschussstrom also der empore land
nicht benötigt wird dazu ein damit
könnte man 240.000 tesla s von lea auf
vorlagen wobei er auto nie leer ist und
auch möglichst immer geladen ist das
heißt man braucht ein vielfaches und
wenn der wind am nächsten tag nicht mehr
weg so wie auch jetzt wieder dann
bräuchte man nur für das burgenland
80.000 es um 300.000 menschen zu
versorgen das heißt dass auch gerne
kommuniziert wird e mobilität wird das
los mit den speichern das ist weit weg
von jeder realität
zum vergleich die heime speichert die
jetzt verbaut werden davon ungefähr zehn
kilowattstunden im vergleich zum tesla
als mit 75 kilowattstunden also auch nur
überschaubare menge und auch dort ist
der speicher reicht de facto nie lea
oder deutlich die windladen
das heißt der elektromobilität und
speicher elektrochemischer speicher
werden sicher teil der lösung sein aber
sicher nicht in der dimension wie wir
uns heute brauchen würden
das thema infrastruktur habe ich schon
angesprochen dass die leitungen fehlen
aber hinzu kommt dass wir eine alternde
infrastruktur haben in österreich ein
schön besser wurde es laufend auch
erneuert wird aber es gibt da eine
aussage wo ich noch an der verifizierung
bin in deutschland dass es über 1000
groß transformatoren gibt das heißt auf
der 220
380 kilovolt ebene um über 500 davon
sind über 50 jahre bei einer
prognostizierten lebensdauer von 60
jahren und
eine erneuerungsrate von zwei bis vier
stück in gesamtdeutschland pro jahr
das heißt es geht sich absehbar nicht
aus und das ist allerdings dass man
einfach bei alibaba bestellt und dann
vom parkett ins geliefert bekommt weil
die haben hunderte tonnen und die kann
man nicht einfach von irgendwo her
transportieren wir das enormen luke ist
die schau findet bedarf
auch wenn es eben den nächsten monaten
nächsten jahre gut geht ist es absurd
dass wir gegen ende des jahrzehnts
spätestens in aus dieser richtung auch
in massiver probleme schlittern werden
weiß er nicht nur um die erneuerung geht
sondern auch um an aus- und umbau und ja
und auch wenn man das jetzt hochskaliert
die fachkräfte muss man dann home und
und und also das geht nicht so schnell
wie das auf dem papier sich oft
darstellen lässt ja und dann haben wir
auch einen steigenden stromverbrauch der
erwartungen in deutschland war bisher
dass der strombedarf bis 20.30
gleichziehen der kollege hat sie das
anschaut wie schaut das mit der
digitalisierung aus was ist da geplant
und hat das mit
stromverbrauch korreliert und ist zum
schluss gekommen dass nicht der
stromverbrauch sinkt sondern deutlich
ansteigen wird wenn man das so betreibt
wird es derzeit geplant ist nämlich der
grüne pfeil nach oben
das heißt auch hier die infrastruktur
ist derzeit am limit und müsste massiv
ausgebaut werden um überhaupt normal und
leichten anstieg vom verbrauch zu
schaffen geschweige denn diese massiven
einstieg das ist derzeit ein satz war
gut böse eichner und es kam auch nicht
so schnell machen wie man jetzt
digitalisierung macht oder wie überhaupt
photovoltaik oder windkraft anlage
aufstellen und der ist auch das was wir
in österreich derzeit mit 20 30 zielen
machen weil ich weit weg von
realisierbar vielleicht zwanzig dreißig
noch über 20 40 ist völlig unrealistisch
weil
20.30 ist eben das ziel
strom bilanziell über sachgerecht und
100 prozent erneuerbar zu schaffen und
dazu muss eine große menge photovoltaik
und pv ausgebaut werden
das problem ist aber nicht die
auszubauen wobei auch das problem ist
bei den derzeit
liefermenge lieferprobleme bestehen und
dann muss man auch die flächen schaffen
und so weiter aber man müsste die ganze
infrastruktur nachziehen und das alleine
wird der 18 milliarden kosten nach
derzeitigen berechnungen
das muss man erst einmal mit
fachpersonal und vor allem auch gerät
umsetzen können was kaum vorstellbar ist
und jetzt muss man sich vorstellen wie
es haben bereits 75 bis zu 80 prozent
des stromverbrauchs erneuerbar das heißt
es geht um 20 prozent die jetzt noch
fehlen und das wird schon eine kaum
bewältigbare aufgabe und dann im sommer
die zielsetzung der bundesregierung bis
20.40 der restlichen 80 prozent
des energieverbrauchs wenn der
stromverbrauch ist nur 20 prozent zum
gesamten energieverbrauch umzustellen
ja da muss man sehr fädeln fantasie
haben oder sehr viel hoffnung dass
irgendwelche neuen technologien gibt der
alles in den schatten stellen ist
derzeit nicht absehbar das andere
problem dabei ist man kann durchaus
ambitionierte ziele haben aber wenn ich
sage ich möchte dass in 19 jahren
erreichen dann muss ich heute schon
entsprechende infrastruktur warum nicht
für zwanzig dreißig sondern für 20 40
und der limburger uns einfach ziemlich
in den sack und das klar auszusprechen
ja und das geht auch mit
elektromobilität auch ein
grossverbraucher oder zumindest wenn das
schnellladen will und das problem ist ja
auch jetzt schon dass die infrastruktur
in den verteilnetzen am limit ist und
dass eine große ausstellung von
elektromobilität in den nächsten jahren
sicher nicht zu erwarten ist weil das
einfach technisch nicht beherrschbar ist
außer nur noch dezentrale speicher wo
man den photovoltaik strom auch
untertags ein zaubertor aus dem netz bin
grad nicht so großer verbrauch ist und
ich danke dann von diesen speicher aber
direkt am netz anhängern das ist
ziemlich schnell am ende
weil das nicht
kompatibel mit der infrastruktur hinzu
kommt das ja auch dieses versehen heizen
und gestellt werden soll auf von
wärmepumpen und auch dessen
grossverbraucher vollmanns kalt und hier
ist das heißt jetzt im winter dann wo
ich eh schon eindeckungs problem habe
und auch da werden wir ziemlich schnell
immens dass das einfach nicht
funktioniert gar nicht nur im großen
sondern auch im kleinen weil dies nicht
sind es nicht verkraften und
bild besser ist als bei der
klimatisierung weil wenn man das
intelligent macht was voraussetzung ist
dann kann man es mit photovoltaik
kombinieren und wollen dann ordentlich
können wenn ganz viel überschussstrom
habe und so das system auch ein bisserl
entlasten
ja und dann gibt es noch eine reihe von
einzelereignissen die das fass zum
überlaufen bringen können
und da gibt es alles mehr von
extremwetterereignissen hatten wir in
polen zum mehrfach 2015 war es zu heiß
und zu trocken zu wenig wasser die
kraftwerke konnten nicht mehr
ausreichend gekühlt werden und wir
wollen auf eskalationsstufe 19 von 20
2020 wird ein starkregenereignis
empfohlen ausschlag geben dass das
größte kohlekraftwerk der welt
ausgefallen ist aber andere auch und wir
waren am limit wir hatten 2020 in der
schweiz einen sabotage anschlag auf zu
einem gittermasten der
ausgeknipst wurde dadurch
windes zum falschen zeitpunkt am
falschen ort ist kann das ausreichen um
eine kettenreaktion auszulösen wir haben
laufend cyberangriffe es gibt keinen
massiven cyber angriff auf einem
zulieferer auch für die e-wirtschaft man
meist nicht was da wirklich weil es
vielleicht schon vorbereitet ist oder
einfach auch von sicher schief geht also
meine sorge ist weniger dass das gezielt
eingesetzt wird sondern dass die
vorbereitungshandlungen etwas auslösen
was niemand reich wollte oder vorgesehen
war
und das was ich erwarte ist ein praxis
dem versagen durch komplexität zu
belastung
keine externe institutionen weil dann
dauert da wieder an noch viel länger das
heißt alles was ich nachts zum thema
black kommt selbst erzähle ist das best
case szenario
und wir können es trotzdem funktionieren
von die energiewende dann müsste man ein
bisschen mehr im system bedenken
naturbeobachtung wer alles lebendig in
der natur so komplexes system und
zelluläre organisiert das hat
offensichtlich sie bewährt und überlebt
und das sollte auch die blaupause für
unserer technischen
systeme in moskau war gott das gegenteil
es gibt eine eu vorgabe bis 20.25 muster
grenzüberschreitende stromhandel auf
mindestens 70 prozent ausgeweitet werden
der als derzeit in österreich um die uni
de oder unter 20 prozent und das heißt
es wird zu massiven belastungen der
infrastruktur führen man nimmt das
bewusst in kauf weil die technik
umkippen kann gewarnt dass das wahnsinn
ist aber das wird ignoriert und der
formation bis gewesen ist dass man
dieses system nicht
dass dieses system nicht mit sich
verhandeln ist und nicht
diese tendenz nun endlich ausweiten kann
und es gab es als eigenes häusermarkt
jänner in kroatien und das war
die warnung schlechthin weil hier großer
stromtransport von balken richtung
frankreich spanien passiert ist weil
preisunterschiede worden und das war ja
auch ziel dieses austausches dieses
handels und deshalb zur belastung dort
eines umspannwerkes geführt und dann zur
großstörung geführt und wir hatten heuer
bereits zwei groß stellen zwei solche
netz auf trennende zweiter und 24 juli
und es gab insgesamt in den letzten
jahrzehnten aber nur 5 na ja auch da
darin weiß es tut sich da was was
vielleicht nicht so positiv ist
positiv war dass es ein recht gut
beherrscht werden konnte aber nicht weil
man damit gerechnet hat sondern kann die
mechanismen gegriffen und das auch rasch
behoben werden konnte das was aber keine
garantie ist dass ich beim nächsten
kontext auch gut funktioniert und
daher hoffe ich dass es mit dem größeren
einstieg vermitteln konnte um so wichtig
ist in zusammenhängen zu denken und
diese zu suchen und sich nicht nur auf
details zu konzentrieren
und daher probleme kann man muss man
dergleichen denkweise lösen mit der sie
entstanden sind wie albert einstein
schon gesagt hat wir versuchen das aber
derzeit in vielen bereichen das ist
warum wir nicht weiterkommen und mit
immer mehr eskaliert start in griff
bekommen werden und ich glaube dass man
da ansetzen muss
und jetzt konkret zur frage bleibt wie
lange dauert so etwas
gute frage was
dann zu beginnen und länger ist als eben
nicht abschätzbar wie lange das ganze
wirklich dauern wird weil wir diese
erfahrungen nicht haben
und es gibt aber simulator zentrum wo
auch die österreichischen netzbetreiber
in deutschland üben und das versuchen
wieder aufzubauen auch mit den
europäischen partnern und daher gibt es
gewisse einschätzungen
und die phase 1 das heißt der strom ist
weg.de strom ist wieder da wird in
österreich rund einen tag erwartet dass
es dauern wird
in gewissen regionen geht es auch
schneller in anderen wird es länger
dauern also es ist grundsätzlich geplant
vom alten kaprun zu starten dann den
großraum wien aufzuschalten das hat der
höhe und vier stunden gedauert wo alles
vorbereitet war und alles um platz war
und dann dauert es auch noch wien jedoch
aussagen es gibt da sperr kabinetts wo
wichtige infrastruktur und aufhängen
dass man selbst hoch fahren möchte wo es
innerhalb von sechs stunden gelingen
soll es gibt dann auch andere aussagen
das aber bis ganz wien wieder versorgt
es 24 bis 48 stunden erwartet
man weiß es nicht und das hängt von
vielen dingen ab unter der planung her
sollte man eher bis zum hochrhein bauen
und dann positiv überrascht werden wie
umgekehrt
wichtig ist auf europäischer ebene wird
und eine woche dauern hoffentlich nur
weil sie auch plausible einschätzungen
gibt dass es durchaus länger dauern kann
weil nicht alles so verbreitet ist wie
in österreich
was wichtig ist auch für uns in
österreich auch wenn wir noch 24 stunden
wieder strom haben heißt das nicht dass
das bleibt weil in dieser simulation es
häufig zu rückschlägen kommt und wieder
diese teile auszählen und
wichtig ist daher wenn der strom am
altar ist zu warten bis du aus dem
bauernbund klar kommuniziert das
gesamtsystem ist großen stabil genug
damit man davon ausgehen kann dass es so
bleibt da sonst konnte jederzeit zum
totalausfall kommen und dann wenn nicht
an schon dinge hochfahren von meta
system wird dann kann ich noch ein
größerer schaden habe
das was leider nach wie vor völlig
unterschätzt wird ist die phase 2 das
heißt die zeit der strom aus wie du da
bist die telekommunikation wieder
funktioniert und hier gibt es viele
unsicherheiten weil man das eben nicht
zu üben kann die im stromnetz und auf
der anderen seite gibt es einfach die
erfahrung aus lokalen ausfällen von it
systemen die 24/7 oft über jahre durch
rennen das geschehen bis zu 30% hudson
auftreten wo netzteile switches dann
auch festplatten server in die stromlose
nicht mehr hochfahren oder kaputt sind
und wenn ich nicht kommentieren kann
kann ich keine ersatzteile
organisieren und diese menge an
ersatzteile gibt es weltweit nicht die
dame weise dann notwendig sind
ja und es funktioniert dann gibt es
natürlich die möglichkeit von störungen
die es auch immer wieder auftritt das
heißt software komfortzonen geben
verloren und dann muss ich auch das
beheben und wenn das auch noch
funktioniert dann habe ich spätestens da
man das netz wieder daher massive
überlastung weil alle gleichzeitig dann
kommunizieren möchten
und ohne telekommunikations versorgen
gibt es weder eine produktion noch in
die logistik noch eine treibstoff
versorgen weil die treibstoffversorgung
hängt nämlich auch großteils von it
systemen ab das dank wegen
gestützt diebstahl gesichert sind und
nur mit einer verbindung in der zentrale
entleeren können
und daher bleibe doch auch diese weitere
zeit völlig im stillstand mit ausnahme
wasser abwasser und heizungssysteme der
ist dann hoffentlich wieder funktioniert
aber alles andere ist weiterhin nur
punktuell vielleicht möglich wenn man
was vorbereitet aber im großen und
ganzen nicht und dann kommen die phase 3
wo wir von monaten und jahren sprechen
so geht etwa erwartet dass binnen
stunden millionen tiere in der
industrialisierten tierhalter quer über
europa versterben oder
verändern und das heißt wir werden hier
massive versorgungsprobleme über längere
zeit sehen was natürlich auch ein thema
für die sicherheit dann ist
glaub schon dass wir als menschen uns
dann darauf einstellen aber es ist dann
sicher nicht alles so wie gewohnt
und es kann auch andere bereiche nicht
nur die fleischproduktion betrifft
und insgesamt werden in diese
lieferketten call option die damit
verbunden sind vom blackout oder vom
blackout ausgelöst werden völlig
unterschätzt
und das heutige jahr hatte uns doch
einiges gezeigt wie einzelereignisse
suez kanal oder der ausfall
oder strohmann gelangen texas wo dann zb
chipfabriken heruntergefahren werden
mussten die haben gesagt geordnet runter
gefahren und haben vier monate wieder
anlaufzeit kommt sein film gedauert dass
wir den normalbetrieb zu haben und ich
glaube es kennt mittlerweile jeder
irgendwelche produkte die derzeit nicht
lieferbar sind weil ihm das ganze system
derzeit aus dem gleichgewicht gerät das
heißt es ist ja auch da anfangen wir
sängers beging der aufstellung und das
wird sich in den nächsten jahren noch
fortsetzen
und ein beispiel dafür es gab letztes
jahr zwei schweine schlachthöfe
schließungen in deutschland im mai und
im juni
aufgrund der krone infektionen
und das hat dazu geführt dass der eine
schlachthof war ca
vier wochen gesperrt und das hat 18
wochen gedauert bis der wieder seine
volle kapazität ausbauen konnte und das
hat dazu geführt dass bis jahresende das
ist kommt auf der grafik ganz darauf
eine million schweine nicht rechtzeitig
geschlachtet werden konnten das konnte
dann nachgeholt werden bis hebel war und
jetzt in die kühlhäuser bis oben hin
gefüllt und jetzt dass dahinter die
ganze ferkelproduktion und die ganze
produktion heruntergefahren worden das
heißt wir haben auch hier ein
schweigendes system
und wie werden die auswirkungen
als kunden erst in den nächsten monaten
möglich zu spüren bekommen weil einfach
die preise bei massiv zum schwanken
beginnen auch
weil arme ist wenig tor
und daher ist auch die wesentliche frage
und das gilt auch für das bundesheer auf
fast bereiten wir uns vor
auf diesen springt diese
notstromversorgung für die phase 1 wobei
beim bundesheer die planungen weiter
gehen aber in vielen gemeinden und so
weiter glaubt man wenn man glück hat
dann ist man black hat vorbereitet was
auch völliger blödsinn ist sondern es
geht eigentlich um diesen marathon das
heißt meine vorgabe ist in den
unternehmen gemeinden oder egal wo 14
tage notbetrieb das heißt sich von
vornherein darauf einzustellen dass ich
14 tage im krisen betrieb bleibe das
heißt ich muss schlichtweg sein ich muss
mit weniger personal auskommen weil die
leute einfach nicht bekommen weil auch
nicht die qualifiziertesten dann immer
zur verfügung stehen werden um
krisen betrieb aufrecht zu halten ich
glaube das wird mit ziemlicher
sicherheit benötigen warum meine mutter
14 tage mich eingestellt vorbereitet bin
und auch im betrieb behindern und
notbetrieb dann kann ich das auch länger
durchführen aber wenn mein
planungshorizont eintrag stromausfall
ist dann werde ich ziemlich schnell
scheitern
nun durch den zeitnahen ausbau der
telekommunikations versorgung kommt es
dazu dass die gesellschaft den kleinen
strukturen zu fallen das heißt in die
familie nachbarschaft und gemeinde
vielleicht noch und darüber hinaus was
wir sonst sehr erfolgreich macht
increase management wird dann nicht
funktioniert und das ist viel auch nicht
bewusst aber das ist halt zu erwarten
sei es eben auch zu erwarten dass die
mobilfunk und festnetz versorgung binnen
minuten wahrscheinlich ausfallen wird
großflächig damit auch internet
punkte er vielleicht länger halbe stunde
oder auch darüber hinaus aber das wäre
nicht die planungsgrundlage sein sondern
man muss davon ausgehen bis man
realisiert hat da ist was los ist kann
man nicht mehr kommunizieren
und wenn man auch krisen management
vorbereitet hat dann bedeutet das dass
man für einen gewissen gröbern auswahl
organisationen vorbereitet ist aber die
frage ist was ist wenn alle bereichen
organisation eines unternehmens
gleichzeitig betroffen sind und man eben
nicht mehr kommunizieren kann um keine
alarmierung wie sonst üblich über
mobilfunk absetzen kann das wird nicht
funktionieren wenn man nicht offline
pläne vorbereitet das heißt jetzt klar
definiere und dass wir auch im
bundesheer mein ansatz
welche schritte sind zu setzen
auch immer unterschiedlichen tages und
jahreszeiten ist es unter der woche in
der arbeitszeit ist es in der nacht ist
es im winter im sommer hat natürlich
unterschiedliche auswirkungen aber das
muss man festlegen dessen ablauf wenn
ich ihn nicht mehr nachfragen kann
was ist dann zu tun damit das nicht in
allein und flüchtiges chaos endet
und auch wenn hier die bundeswehr in
deren oder in organisationen in der
regener kommunikationsmedium
funktioniert sollte der plan trotz 2000
wenn man das nicht getestet hat dann ist
keine garantie dass das funktioniert und
auch dann gibt es noch immer die
möglichkeit dass dinge ausfallen und er
sollte ich diesen plan haben und wenn es
besser funktioniert haben wir erinnern
uns ausbildung gelernt dann sollen wir
uns freuen aber das darf nicht der beste
es darf nicht die planungsgrundlage sein
zentrale frage ist natürlich wieder
farbe dass es so weit ist doch gibt es
ein bettler positiv erachte ich das
radio funktioniert weiter dorfkern zu -
72 stunden weitersenden in manchen
regionen sogar deutlich länger
das heißt gebrauchen gemeinden
empfangsgerät von patrick göbel radio
über autoradio dass viele nicht an
berater haben oder auch smartphones
ältere generation möchte noch einen
kopfhörer mit kabel anschließen kann das
ist der diner dann kann ich dann
empfangen und dann bleibt nunmal face to
face wo ich direkt miteinander
kommunizieren kann oder mit mobilität
das bislang ausweiten kann
und
dann gibt die wesentlichen indikatoren
strom ist weg es immer auch bei lokalen
ausfällen dann den mobilfunk oder
smartphone hier nehmen und schon habe
ich noch netz wenn jemand anrufen der
weiterweg sich gerade aufhält um
festzustellen habt ihr auch gerade einen
stromausfall an
radio einschalten werden nicht mehr alle
sender dasein auf die drei schalten mary
drei national verfügbar ist oder
österreich weiß verfügbar ist und
gleichzeitig auch den verkehrsfunk hat
und das ist eben der 4ten diktator
mobilen ist euch im vorteil weil der
asfinag news binnen eineinhalb stunden
eine dose spielen die großen sofort weil
die sicherheitsstromversorgung nicht
ausreicht um das länger aufrecht zu
halten wenn ich ihn höre ist wer in
österreich mit nudel gesperrt dann kann
ich davon ausgehen es ist soweit
und bis dann offiziell was kommt es wird
sicher ein zwei stunden dauern um bis zu
tun haben aber dann schon wichtige zeit
gewonnen wenn ich gleich darauf zu
reagieren beginne und sollte es doch
noch nicht soweit sein wenn man das weiß
nur österreich jetzt betrifft großen
teilen österreichs und man kann das
schnell wieder herstellen da kommt man
zumindest bleibt vermutet aber davor die
lage kommen wie abzuwarten und dann böse
überrascht zu werden
auch die organisierte hilfe ist nur mehr
eingeschränkt handlungsfähig das heißt
viele falsche erwartungen weil die
feuerwehr hatte er notstromaggregat
glauben für den bürgermeister und damit
werden sie die wirtschaft versorgen ist
natürlich blödsinn das wird alles nicht
funktionieren und es gilt auch gegenüber
dem bundesheer weil das bundesheer ja
immer kommt wenn die anderen nicht mehr
können sie jetzt auch wieder carola oder
auch waldbrand und so weiter
und das ist durchaus eine verhaltene
erwartungen und das geht es glaube ich
auch noch schärfer klarzustellen das
bundesheer ist jetzt am weg sich selbst
handlungsfähig zu machen dann
hoffentlich helfen zu können aber auch
wenn das bundesheer alle ressourcen
schon hätte und
alles möglich wäre auch
55.000 mann mit ausrüsten können nicht
neun millionen menschen versorgen und
helfen das wird immer nur punktuell
gelingen und ich glaube dass es ganz
wichtig eine kommunikation diese
klarstellung auch herzustellen
ja und ein beispiel wo man glaubt dass
man vorbereitet ist und wo es aus meiner
erfahrung ich nicht das ist es in dem
die krankenhäuser was uns alle danach
betreffen wird oder krankenhäuser haben
zu einer notstromversorgung für
zumindest 24 stunden die jetzt durchaus
ausgeweitet wird aber das ist nur ein
teilproblem weil die frage ist
funktioniert die wasserversorgung von
außen wenn nicht dann die sofort schluss
mit krankenhausbetrieb
und da gibt es ein beispiel wo im
krankenhaus kritisiert zwei redundante
angeschlossen also passt und dann wurde
nachgefragt woher kommt das wasser ja
was man nicht dann hat man auch schaut
und dann hat man festgestellt dass kommt
aus den gleichen hochbehälter
also beide leitungen aus denselben
hochbehälter damit dass mit der gleichen
pumpe gefüllt wird die nicht nur strom
versorgt ist das heißt zeitnah ein
problem
dann auch das thema medikamenten medizin
güterversorgung duo war bis vor wenigen
monaten mein kenntnisstand der um 14
tage vorgeschrieben
dass vorrätig zu halten um dann habe ich
gelernt neben verschiedenen
krankenhäuser und dass das nicht überall
der fall mehr ist sondern das ist just
in time vom lieferanten eingeliefert das
heißt wir haben nur wenige ressourcen
vor ort mehr auch hier im geist ist geil
und das könnte dann ziemlich böse
aufpoppen gleiche gilt mit den
ausgesuchten bereichen reinigung
oder wäsche
und auch in den charakter was das so gut
beim notstrom aufgestellt ist hat man
festgestellt am zweiten tag wäre keine
opfer mehr möglich gewesen weil der op
begleitung täglich angeliefert wird
keine reinigung mehr möglich gewesen
weil das täglich aufbereitet wird und
nicht am notstrom gegangen ist
die küche war auch nicht am notstrom ja
das haben jetzt abgestellt aber das ist
oft nicht wirklich klar oder wirklich
umgesetzt und dann kommt das nächste
thema wie viele lebensmittel sind
vorrätig und erreicht oft von ein bis
sieben tagen das heißt es wird sich
nicht ausgehen dies wieder logistik
funktioniert dass man die versorgung
aufrecht erhalten und dann natürlich das
große fragezeichen personal woher kommt
das personal kommt es noch zur ablöse
kann es bleiben und so weiter und meine
erfahrung ist dass die technik im
krankenhaus sich sehr wohl mit dem thema
beschäftigt und versucht ihr
absicherungen zu treffen aber das ist
eben kein technisches problem sondern
ein gesamtproblem und bin das
wachpersonal ärzte pflegerinnen
reinigungskräfte und so weiter nicht
vorbereitet sind nicht bleiben oder
nicht kommen dann funktioniert der
gesamte betrieb nicht
und das große problem ist auch außerhalb
weil die gesamte dezentralen
gesundheitsversorgung auch nicht
funktioniert apotheken essen auf rädern
funktioniert nicht mehr pflegeheim
pflege funktioniert niedergelassenen
ärzte und wenn es da nicht schaffen eine
notversorgung aufzubauen dann wir haben
die korrekten häuser ziemlich schnell
verlieren weil es überlastet sind und
nicht mehr zurande kommen werden
ja in städtischen raum großen wien finde
ich im verkehr bricht natürlich
untertags tallec zusammen weil die
ampeln ausfallen die straßenbahnen
möglicherweise
blockieren auch wissen dem was sind die
bahnhöfe auch in anderen ortschaften
weil der öbb zwar in der lage ist
zumindest die züge nach und nach in die
bahnhöfe zu ziehen aber es wird kein
betrieb weiter aufrecht halten und es
kann nicht weil der infrastruktur und
die sicherheitseinrichtung im
öffentlichen netz ändert
das heißt in den ortschaften war bahnhof
ist können dann möglicherweise hunderten
oder noch mehr menschen stranden
was beim im winter ziemlich schnell
eskalieren kann und das dann auch so hot
spots war vielleicht das bundesheer dann
angefordert werden könnte
wichtig ist der überhaupt systeme
alarmanlagen und das hat man ja bei der
gabelung auch gesehen vor einem jahr
wenn man dann nicht mehr zu den waffen
oder munition kommt dann ist das belohnt
günstig betrifft auch schließanlagen
wenn ich nicht mehr reinkomme man kommt
immer raus aber man kommt nicht mehr
rein und das muss man ja auch anschauen
bis hin dass im alarmanlagen die dann
pfeifen wo auch die verkleidungen
auftreten können wo ich dann auch an
impfstellen schaden zu erwarten habe
natürlich der große beleuchtung wie
funktioniert die beleuchtung
notbeleuchtung weil das natürlich auch
keine verletzungsgefahr ist wenn leute
stürzen und so weiter und da muss man
auch einiges erwarten
winter jetzt natürlich auch ein großes
thema problem mit einheizen das heißt es
wird die brandgefahr steigen und das
große problem ist dass man eben nicht
anrufen kann um eine feuerwehr zu rufen
und der wiener brand entsteht trotz
ziemlich zeit nach größerer brand und
das was bei anderen großprojekten
passiert das einfach die feuerwehren aus
der ganzen region zusammengezogen werden
es wird ziemlich schnell limitiert sein
und hinzu kommt noch wenn wir ein
problem bei der wasserversorgung besteht
dann ist einen löschen überhaupt nicht
mehr möglich das heißt brandschutz ist
ein ganz ganz zentraler punkt
der aufrechtzuhalten ist um das muss man
einfach durch die feuerwachen oder
beurteilungs post und so weiter auch
sicherstellen damit man frühzeitig
solche dinge auch erkennen kann
wasser versorgen ist in österreich zwar
besser aufgestellt oder wesentlich
besser wenn in deutschland aber auch
hier gibt es oftmals probleme ich weiß
nicht ob ich war schwarzenbergkaserne
schon abgesichert ist aber vor fünf
jahren dass die aussage dass nach sechs
stunden die wasserversorgung nicht mehr
funktioniert wenn das so wäre dann kann
man nicht zu versperren
und auch wenn im winter aussage ist die
wasserversorgung funktioniert dann ist
das nur teilweise wichtig weil ab dem
sechsten stock witz probleme gelten
druck
bis hin dass hoch sms druck steigerungs
anlage haben und sofort ausfallen und
wenn das wasser nicht mehr funktioniert
dann habe ich sofort der hygieneproblem
das heißt ich kann nicht mehr speziell
geben wenn die spülung einmal bestätigt
wurde
um bis hin dann zum abwasser was auch
häufige problem gibt wenn das wasser
durch hebeanlagen in den öffentlichen
kanal gepumpt werden muss war zb ein
hochhaus dann kommt es irgendwo im
erdgeschoss oder im keller wieder raus
oder auch bei tiefer gelegenen gebieten
wo das abwasser aus der ganzen region
dann austritt
er hatte gesagt die logistische
vernetzung alles ist strom unter gap das
heißt geldsystem fällt sofort auf
supermärkte brauchen strom für die
kassen beleuchtung für die kühlung ich
bin gerade dabei mit den
lebensmittelketten hier einige maßnahmen
anzustoßen vorher das geordnete abgeben
von verderblichen waren damit die nicht
verderben sorgt der müssen und versuchen
zur verfügung stellen und das seitdem
müssen und der schutz der einrichtungen
treibstoffversorgung funktioniert
großflächig nicht und
medikamentenversorgung komme schon
gesundheitsversorgung eben auch nicht
da können wir da was aufmachen sollte
damit das ziemlich schnell solche bilder
geben wie man das auch vor über einem
jahr gesehen haben bei mir vor dem
ersten lok dauern nur dort hat die
logistik noch funktioniert und hier
funktioniert sie noch nicht und das
heißt wenn es leer es ist leer und das
wird länger dauern bis das wieder was
nachgeliefert werden kann punkte der
ausnahmen immer möglich
noch schlimmer wie alles was zerstört
werden würde so kaputt ist dann kann man
dann noch viel länger keine versorgen
wir hin und der als eines der zentralen
aufgaben für uns als gesellschaft
polizei wird es nicht schaffen
bundeswehr wahrscheinlich auch nicht
den schutz der verkaufseinrichtung und
sicher zu stellen einfach durch
anwesenheit das heißt dass man personen
vorne hinstellt die einfach die
gelegenheit
abwenden dass man einfach bei der
nächsten gelegenheit sich was holt wenn
man glaubt man braucht noch was wenn es
natürlich dann weiter eskaliert und die
gewohnt gewalt angedroht wird dann ist
eh vorbei aber möglichst lange diesem
tiefpunkt in motion
und das zentrale problem sind wir als
bevölkerung die glauben aber es ist
funktioniert der ehemals und wenn nicht
dann wird der staat uns versorgen wie
die jüngste umfrage wieder gezeigt hat
wo drei viertel der teilnehmer sorgten
beim mehrwöchigen
versorgungsunterbrechung wird der staat
uns versorgt wenn man starrt wie alle
richtig versteht dann stimmt das aber
ich glaube nicht dass das so gemeint war
und wenn die normale produktion und
verteilung nicht funktioniert
funktioniert das auch nicht über
irgendein staatliche struktur und das
große zentrale problemen beim black ort
ist unsere naivität weil wir wissen dass
ein drittel der bevölkerung maximal vier
tage und dann weiter drittel sich
maximal eine woche selbst versorgen kann
und nur ein drittel ist in der lage hat
das länger zu machen
und wenn man am ende erst noch rund
sechs millionen menschen in österreich
haben die man lebenskampf sind spricht
die haben nichts mehr zu essen die sehen
die supermärkte sind leer oder zerstört
und es kommt nichts dann macht es nicht
unbedingt positiv kreativ und das andere
problem ist dass auch das personal jener
davon betroffen ist die dann im
notbetrieb aufrechterhalten müssen oder
die die produktion und logistik wieder
hochfahren müssen und wenn der zu hause
mit lebenskampf sind und der familie im
überlebenskampf ist dann kommen die
nicht in der arbeit und daher ist das
sind ein problem und
ja das man sprechen muss
und das andere ist dass bei einem
blackout die menschen alle von dem
eigenes betroffen sind und nicht wie bei
anderen ereignissen damit der
schadensbewältigung beschäftigt sind
sondern einfach nichts zu tun haben und
viele sind nicht in der lage damit
umzugehen gehst dann auch wieder
veranstaltungen mit studentenheimen
wollte ich so kommen das internet aus
freut dann ist die hölle los
und daher muss man diese
ressourcen auch kanalisieren und dass
wir auch aufgewühlt gleich richtung
bundeswehr in sage ich versuche im
dienst zu bilden die genau solche
ungebundenen helfer oder die dann zum
gebunden und helfer werden
zu organisieren und für dinge
einzusetzen einerseits um zum beispiel
pflegebereich zu helfen oder in anderen
bereichen zu helfen und meinte nur
beschäftigt werden müllsammelaktion oder
was auch immer aber beschäftigt werden
müssen
und dass was leider auch immer wieder
auftaucht dass jene der vorsorgen sich
oft sorgen fürchten war sie sagen ja ich
habe schon was aber der rest nicht und
daher muss ich mich verstecken oder
bewaffnet muss durchaus nachvollziehbar
ist aber noch probleme schafft weil
windows unser erster gedanke ist wie man
sowas angehender normal herzgesellschaft
sehr zeitnah verloren
insgesamt der sollte sich immer brachte
es egal ob in unternehmen oder jetzt
auch im staat selbst auf welcher ebene
auch immer war es gibt erwartungen die
nach außen kommuniziert werden die sich
in keinster weise mit der wirklichkeit
decken also unternehmens für die sagen
ja wir sind vorbereitet und wir haben
hier ein notstromaggregat und wenn man
dann rein geht in die usa ziehen und
personalabbau fragen stellt am meisten
sofort dass nichts vorbereitet ist und
strom kriege hat kann schon teil der
lösung sein und wir sind dagegen nur
kleiner teil sein
ja und dann wird die frage wer ist
verantwortlich zuständig
ja da gibt es viele mögliche kandidaten
das was ich heute in den letzten zehn
jahren sind häufig erlebt habt es wird
im kreis gekommen ist wird immer waren
das gesehen beginnt damit dass der
katastrophenschutz länder soll jetzt
durch das als krisen sicherheitsgesetze
etwas geändert werden aber das ist im
ersten begutachtung und nicht realität
und auch wenn es beschlossen ist muss
das gelebte sache werden und da braucht
es noch viel mehr
weil ja dass er mentale sache ist und
nicht so sehr legistische
und daher eine klare ansage wir alle
haben hier eine gesellschaftliche
verantwortung das heißt wir müssen uns
selbst beginnen
dass der eigene familie gut versorgt ist
das umfeld hoffentlich irgendwie auch
aktivieren können dann natürlich auch in
den organisationen in den gemeinden nach
bohren und hartnäckig bleiben uns
erfahren was ist wirklich vorbereitet
bzw entsprechende vorbereitungen
anzustoßen
und
geht dann weiter auch mit dem wissen in
der familie auch jetzt im bundesheer
ganz wichtiger punkt auch das zu
kommunizieren
dass die soldaten und soldatinnen oder
auch angehalten mit ihrer familie
darüber reden wenn man weiß man muss in
den dienst gehen in den einsatz gehen
oder bleiben
damit der familie weiß das wird zu sein
und die kommt nicht nach hause wenn wir
selbst betroffen sind wie die
familienzusammenführungen schon
funktioniert wenn das untertags passiert
und die kinder mit öffentlichen verkehr
in der schule sind wir kommen nach hause
und dass man da einfach ein bisschen
raus wenn die inter situation und die
psychologie sagt ganz klar wenn die
leute nicht wissen was mit den
angehörigen ist dann kann man sie
vergessen sie sind nicht handlungsfähig
jetzt natürlich nicht alle betreffen wir
sollen ja dauer bisschen mehr trainiert
aber wir haben auch kameraden die sehr
wohl dann abschalten und das sollte man
durch im vorfeld aufklärung information
anregung ein bisschen entgegnen und dann
die wichtigste vorsorge erste hilfe
medikamente ein geforderten
hilfsmittel die ja auch dazu gehören
immer wieder das thema ja was mache ich
mit dem abgelaufenen dinge essen mit
konserven halten jahrzehnten auch nudeln
und reis halten deutlich länger und dann
muss man auch den hausverstand
einschalten
und das was man als im bodensee schon
danke auch an markus im laufen haben ist
diese aufklärung des personals und
aufforderung zur eigenvorsorge weil das
ist der einzige chance dass man als
organisation nach wirklich
handlungsfähig
wir haben kann und oder bleibt und das
ist auch die empfehlung dieser anderen
organisationen wenn sie gefragt werden
oder in gemeinden weitergeben sollen das
personal ist an erster stelle nicht das
notstromaggregat und
dann geht es um die nachbarschaftshilfe
zu organisieren damit eben die leute
aufeinander schauen wenn die
pflegedienste nicht kommen wenn notrufe
notwendig sind wenn man wasser in dem 15
stock tragen muss weil die alte dame ist
nicht holen kann und solche dinge
und dann geht es auch um diese
dezentrale selbstorganisation in
gemeinden form das heißt wir sind
gewohnt dass man zum hörer greifen und
dann kommt die einsatzorganisation und
binnen minuten das funktioniert da alles
nicht und der muss man in den gemälden
der zentrale anlaufstellen selbsthilfe
passen vorbereiten wo man vorbereitet
dass eine kommunikation funktioniert um
einen notruf absetzen kann und wo man
auch hierfür anbieten kann und hilfe
abholen kann das heißt dass sich die
bevölkerung einfach um diesen
kristallisationspunkt selbst organisiert
und nicht erwartet dass irgendjemand
alles vollen service markt
und eben der punkt bevölkerung einbinden
habe ich angesprochen ich glaube dass
das sinnvoll wir den völkern auch
aufzufordern die warnweste anzulegen
damit auch gewisse uniform zu zeigen und
zu kommunizieren dass menschen jahr
waren es dann haben bereits um zu helfen
dass man sie anspricht und damit schafft
man auch in der struktur und gibt das
gefühl es funktioniert noch etwas und
wenn diese persönliche und
nachbarschaftlicher ebene nicht da ist
was derzeit eben über bruck haft da ist
dann können wir darauf setzen oder
deutsch was man wollen es wird heute nur
sehr eingeschränkt ist gar nicht
funktionieren
und dann gibt es nur der einfach nur
historische maß nehmen
da es meine empfehlung immer vom basis
szenario auszugehen auch in österreich
einen längeren stromausfall nur
anzudenken oder immer
auch den plan zu haben was ist wenn man
eine notstromversorgung ausfällt egal ob
es der treibstoff nicht reicht egal ob
das eher technische störung ist aber
nicht sollte wissen was ist die
konsequenz wenn das ausfällt und wie
kann ich dann noch was macht nur das
einfach dann aus daneben bis zu einer
woche
telekommunikations ausfällt der
hoffentlich kürzer tagen wird in
österreich aber dort war der
stromausfall länger als 72 stunden
dauert dort wissen wir nicht ob wir
diese systeme wieder hochfahren können
weil dann die ganzen backend-systeme
ausfallen und dann haben wir wirklich
ein problem
die versorgungsunterbrechung 14 tage
modells das sich hoffentlich wieder
beginnt einzupendeln
die zielsetzung ist insgesamt immer
höchst geringe gesellschaftliche schäden
davonzutragen und überleben das heißt
nicht dass wir geworden sind alles an
luxus und komfort das ist alles
irrelevant es geht hier wirklich um die
überlebensfrage
wobei ist niemand also es wird niemand
noch mehr und sagen verhungern sowie
kommen durchaus zwei wochen auch eine
links mittel zuvor aus aber es machte
mich sehr kreativ und man muss diese
drei tage muss das wirklich auch
schmerzhaft sein kann man überwinden und
das sagen alle gefassten länger fasten
am vierten tag ist es kein problem mehr
dann ist das egal wenn man keine ersten
hat aber bis dahin muss man aushalten
ja und dann gibt es in gemeinden auch
verschiedene handlungsfelder bin ich
jetzt nur so mal hingeben nach der
spielzeit ich weiter bin wo wir auch
jetzt versuchen bundes jahr da
richtungen unterstützung von gemeinden
ja einzusetzen zu mobilisieren weil ich
glaube alles was wir jetzt im vorfeld
machen können und wir also daten haben
wir da einfach keine bessere
voraussetzungen mit ressourcen
ausbildung und so weiter wenn wir
schaffen den gemeinden entsprechende
dinge anzustoßen und wenn es nur in der
eigenen heimatgemeinde ist dann haben
wir nachher eine zusammen weniger
probleme und auch das bundesheer
profitiert indirekt damit das hat dann
nicht alles im chaos
endete
und da wäre es doch wichtig die
vorleistung zu gehen und ich glaube dass
das auch ganz wichtige aufgabe für das
bundesheer wäre auch im sinne der
umfassend lagers verteidigung auch wenn
es jetzt nicht unmittelbar mit unserem
grundverständnis militärische
landesverteidigung zu tun hat aber wir
haben derzeit keine anderen ressourcen
und wir können darauf auch einen
wichtigen beitrag leisten und da gibt es
auch hilfestellung dieser arbeitsmappe
werden für den zivilschutzverband starke
erstellt haben es gibt auch eine
abgespeckte version von mir selbst weil
die offizielle version erst heuer
freigegeben worden ist für die
allgemeinheit dann kann man einfach
nachschauen ist alles sagt meine
homepage verlinkt und abrufbar
das heißt es geht um sehr viel
kommunikationsarbeit und das wird oft
unterschätzt man glaubt man muss in
einer technik investieren aber mein
zugang ist man muss zuerst einmal
zusammensetzen die köpfe zusammenstecken
was ist wirklich notwendig große ist
wirklich aber sinnvoll die bayerischen
männer und vor allem vorbereiten vom
nicht nur die experten oder wo er
ausgewählte sondern alle zusammen und
dann kommt mir gut drauf ja ich brauche
eine technische maßnahme auch oder nicht
aber das kommunikativer dass es ganz
zentral in der vorbereitung und auch in
der bewältigung
und nur kurz da hinten meist noch ich
habe dann den letzten feier mit einem
spiel entwickler ein planspiel
entwickelt wo man so black ort situation
in einer kleinstadt simulieren aber wo
es einfach kommt das zusammenspiel im
kampf der verbundenen waffen
üben kann und vor allem auch die
unterschiedlichen eigentlich so
auftreten kann ins bewusstsein zu rufen
also damit auch die vorsorge aber weiter
anzustoßen und meine mein mundwerk zu
richten und bunter sehr dass man es auch
mit trainern vom bundes jahr
vorantreiben weil es ist so gestaltet
dass das kommt sich selbst gespielt
werden kann aber es ist doch etwas
komplexer und wenn man da vielleicht
trainer auch in der miliz oder
grundwehrdiener die interessiert sind
die spieler ausbilden könnten dann
könnte man auch gesellschaftlich weder
einen großen mehrwert leisten die
produktion läuft jetzt gerade an das
heißt ich rechne das anfang des jahres
dann wirklich verfügbar sendet und das
andere was ich gerade mit der
historischen gesellschaft für
krisenvorsorge versuche ist die
etablierung der dachmarke krisen wird wo
wir mit dem lebensmittel handelt gerade
gespräche führen dass konkrete vorsorge
pakete oder artikel gibt und er mit
dieser tag dachmarke kommuniziert wird
muss nicht nur ein blackout um vorsorge
geht sondern auch als mentale
vorbereitung auf turbulente zeiten wie
sie derzeit zu erwarten sind dann wird
wie wir als gesellschaft wieder etwas
residieren da wären was wir derzeit dem
de facto nicht sind
damit zum schluss ich glaube wo beim den
kreis wahrscheinlich eh schon klar wo
arbeitet vielleicht nicht die ganze
dimension blackout ist ein
katastrophenszenario videos bisher noch
nicht kennen
das was mir aber wichtig ist es ist ein
beispiel das kann auch was anderes
passieren und die pandemie haben wir als
in teilen schon wobei die in nicht
milder verlaufen ist weil alle
simulationen und die dazu von der
wissenschaftler von anderen bereichen
gemacht wurden kommune nicht zum
ergebnis dass viel mehr ausfälle gibt
das hauspersonal ausfälle und damit
würden wir ziemlich war schauten
versorgungsprobleme kommen bis hin zum
kollaps von ganze lieferketten oder auch
zum blackout wenn in das
stromversorgungssystem nicht mehr
gesteuert werden kann und da gibt es nur
eine handvoll leid oft in den leitwarten
man diese mannschaft aus fort dann wird
es eher kritisch bis m die möglichkeit
dass es wirklich zum kollaps kommt
und dann aspekte war mir auch immer
wichtiger schutz kritischer
infrastruktur selber sicherheit sind
wichtig aber wir müssen auch um stärker
mit dem thema beschäftigen was macht ihr
wenn das nicht ausgereicht hat es zu den
schäden kommt wie wir es auch im
serverbereich gott massiv sehen dass
eben ganze unternehmen verschlüsselt
werden wie gehe ich mit so version
gegeben dass es dann nicht nur mehr um
die infrastruktur geht und dass die
leistungen der endauswahl wo durchaus
auch kettenreaktionen ausgelöst werden
können
und damit das jetzt mal ein input teile
durchaus gefallen aber ich hoffe ich
konnte doch noch den ein oder anderen
aspekt mit geben den sie auch in der
kommunikation dann hoffentlich aufnehmen
können um das thema klarer bewusster und
die tragweite auch bewusster zu machen
damit die vorsorge immer ein wichtiges
thema ist
und auch endlich angegangen werden muss
und nicht nur aktionistische
wunschvorstellung und kommuniziert
werden
die nachkommen